TODAY.
TONY?
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CBS NEWS LEGAL ANALYST RIKKI
KLIEMAN JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING.
YOU HEARD JAMIE SAID THAT TODAY
WILL BE A SHORT DAY.
SO WEEK ONE OF THIS TRIAL IS
NEARLY IN THE BOOKS.
WHAT STOOD OUT TO YOU?
>> THIS HAS BEEN A VERY
EMOTIONAL WEEK.
MUCH MORE EMOTIONAL THAN WE HAVE
SEEN ALMOST IN ANY TRIAL.
EMOTION OF PEOPLE WHO TAKE THE
WITNESS STAND ONE BY ONE AS
EYEWITNESSES, EAR WITNESSES,
FACT WITNESSES, WHAT THEY SAW,
WHAT THEY HEARD, AND IT BRINGS
THE ENTIRE INCIDENT BACK TO
ANGUISH.
THIS IS EXCRUCIATINGLY PAINFUL
TESTIMONY FOR THESE WITNESSES
AND, THEREFORE, FOR THE JURORS,
AS WELL.
WE NEVER SEE A WEEK OF WITNESSES
WITH VIDEOTAPE BECAUSE THE
VIDEOTAPE IN AND OF ITSELF MIGHT
BE ENOUGH TO HELP THE
PROSECUTION GET TO ITS BURDEN OF
PROOF BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT.
>> AND YET WE JUST HEARD THAT
ACCORDING TO ONE LEGAL EXPERT
THAT OUR JAMIE YUCCAS SPOKE TO
THE DEFENSE COULD FILE FOR A
MISTRIAL BECAUSE A POLICE
SERGEANT THAT WE HEARD FROM
YESTERDAY MADE A COMMENT ABOUT
USE OF FORCE.
IT WOULD SEEM TO HAVE HELP THE
PROSECUTION, BUT COULD IT HURT
TH
THEM?
>> DEFENSE LAWYERS MOVE FOR MANY
MISTRIALS DURING THE COURSE OF A
TRIAL.
IN PART TO PRESERVE AN ISSUE FOR
APPEAL IF A DEFENDANT WERE TO BE
CONVICTED.
IN THIS CASE, THE POLICE
OFFICER, THE SERGEANT, GAVE AN
OPINION.
THE QUESTION WAS DO YOU HAVE AN
OPINION ON THE ULTIMATE ISSUE
WHICH IS WHETHER OR NOT THERE
WAS EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE.
HE WAS NOT QUALIFIED.
WOULD IT BE REVERSIBLE ERRO